talk to us about what's unfolding as we
speak Sean well part of the challenge is
the simple maths we're concerned about
will we be able to get everybody out
given there's only a 24-hour window
before the ceasefire is that exactly as
Alex was talking about and the math
doesn't quite add up at the moment
they've had three flights out they are
C-130 Hercules generally carries about
120 people 140 squeeze max number of 400
people so far coming out but actually
they're only two-thirds of that number
have actually appeared on the ground at
Cyprus part of the answer for that is
the RAF is operating out of the what is
seized Air Base up to the north to the
west of the of the of the Nile there
which is some Way north of Khartoum
International Airport now because of the
threat the c-130s will not want to hang
around on the ground they will literally
land pile the people in the back who are
there and get airborne again they won't
be waiting for a full aircraft they'll
just be taking uh whoever's there so
almost certainly this is not actually
about the capacity of the aircraft to
get people out it's whether or not the
Nationals can actually make their way up
to the air base or whether they've
actually chosen a different choice of
how to get out because the air base
there is about 25 kilometers North
that's as the crow flies but as you can
see to get across the river and then
through the tortuous network of uh of
blockades and and stuff like that it's
incredibly difficult and with two to
three thousand foreign Nationals there
just do the maths it's very unlikely
they'll get in 24 hours the butt though
here is the footage we've been seeing of
RAF deployed Personnel on the ground at
the air base means that we are actually
potentially providing some a perimeter
defense here this there'll be some
Medics yes there'll be some admin there
but they've also providing a degree of
protection and there may be the
opportunity that because this is some
Way north of where the fighting is that
the British government judges that
actually we can provide enough security
here to continue the air Bridge even
when the ceasefire ends because frankly
the warring factions will be having goes
to each other and not at this Air Base
remains to be seen so when we're talking
about thousands of UK Nationals inside
Sudan the government's talking about
getting hundreds out 301 at the moment
is the latest figure we're hearing it
could be to do with the treacherous
Journeys the danger involved in getting
to any places where evacuations are
taking place but in terms of the
government doing what it can to provide
an evacuation for numbers if they can
reach there could they provide bigger
planes I know it sounds very simplistic
but when we're talking about getting big
numbers out in quite a tight time frame
now unless they extend that ceasefire is
that possible it definitely is I mean
the choice of aircraft you have with a
civilian or military or even a specter
of military is all based on the state of
the wrong way the risk involved if we
have a look at cartoon which is the
international airport at the moment
um you know it's a big well-found base
and it's fantastic but you don't have to
look this is the 18th of April this is
the fighting that's going on so close
and since then the warring factions have
been trying to take control of this so
stray bullets explosions that is nowhere
that you'd be wanting to operate
civilian aircraft if you look absolutely
at what is that by the wrong way
um from a military perspective is a
patchwork of different repairs it is not
the same quality it will have a load of
debris on it in various parts they don't
sweep it regularly and if you remember
most civilian aircraft have their
engines under the wing that risks
sucking up stuff from the ground most
military tactical aircraft have them on
top of the wing so they can operate in
this sort of environment so for the
civilian aircraft more capacity but this
is not the place for them for a military
perspective they also have defensive Aid
Suites they have a military Cruiser used
to operate in high threatening
environments and the mod will have done
a risk and a vulnerability assessment
and decided that the Hercules and the
a400m are the right platforms the
challenge is how many are available if
it becomes an issue of capacity then
what they can do is turn down the wick
on the way they're supplying Ukraine at
the moment obviously backwards and
forwards with weapons bullets and people
and actually turn up the wick for uh for
Sudan but that's all about supply and
demand we'll have to wait and see what
happens there yeah it's still very much
a fluid situation and but what are the
other options in terms of if people
can't get to an Airbase or it becomes
too dangerous
is there options of going into bordering
countries what about C what about ships
well the first one to look at is they
talked about why don't people go into
cartoon why don't we put British
soldiers in there pluck people out and
take them out that would be incredibly
dangerous there's already two different
forms of Warring factions in military
uniform by all accounts there's lots of
people who are looting there's lots of
trouble it's Lawless to actually put
another military organization that will
be incredibly risky not only for our
military but also the people they were
trying to escort that's not an option
driving is an option um some of them are
driving north to Egypt that's one of the
options uh to get out the country part
of the challenge there is that there's
roadblocks and also how to get hold of
fuel incredibly difficult there the
other one that's probably going to be
create volume is via C via Port Sudan
here because other nations have already
taken out people from there they're all
Navy is already looking at taking
Lancaster type 23 frigate and also
um the cardigan Bay both of which could
carry hundreds if not into the thousands
of people but again we're talking about
500 miles of travel so for the time
being it looks almost certainly I think
the focus will be on the air Bridge not
only because it can be done quickly but
whilst they can balance that risk versus
benefit they'll continue to get people
out using that air bridge out to Cyprus
okay Sean thank you as we said that uh
ceasefire ending tomorrow at midnight
really is a Race Against Time For Those
UK Nationals inside Sudan thank you for
the moment